thank you so in this talk I'm going to
be discussing habit lab which is a
behavior change system that built a
number of in the wild behavior change
experiments that we have conducted on
this platform so the underlying
motivation here is that people are
spending increasing amounts of time
online and with the average u.s. adult
now spending nearly six hours a day with
digital media and this number is only
increasing with time and as evidenced by
the emergence of terms like Facebook
addiction people are struggling to
reduce the time online so as a result a
number of productivity tools have
emerged to help users reduce the time
online such as rescue time and stay
focused are among the tools that said
the way that these basically these tools
work is that you just have a goal in
mind for example to spend less time on
it on Facebook and there are a number of
interventions that are available so for
example the intervention might be to
block Facebook and then there's some
outcome that this tool desires to
achieve for example decreasing the
amount of time on Facebook and I believe
that online behavior change systems is
actually a domain that's very
well-suited for studying these domains
and their outcomes specifically in the
context of outcomes we can actually
measure outcomes very precisely that is
every time you visit the site we can
actually measure exactly how much time
you spend on these we can contrast this
to other behavior change domains for
example dieting where you actually need
the person to self-report like what they
ate everyday for example and then
interventions there's actually many
interventions that are possible in this
specifically anything that you can draw
on the computer screen can be an
intervention and you're not eating at
that intervention is very quickly that
is every time future visits you can
actually deploy new one that is that
said current prior to v2 let's make a
number of assumptions about
interventions and your outcomes
specifically with regards to outcomes we
assume that their effectiveness persists
over time as opposed to for example it's
effective the first day and
progressively the time that you spend
just increases right as the
effectiveness is the clients and there's
also an assumption that there's an
implicit assumption that there's no
negative externalities that is not going
to be influencing time on other sites
and apps
outside that the one targeted by the
intervention we also have number
assumptions about the interventions
themselves that is there's an assumption
that a single intervention is going to
be able to meet most of the user needs
aka one-size-fits-all for interventions
and that users are good at predicting
what interventions will work for them so
he's developed to have a lab as some
mechanism to say whether or not these
assumptions are actually true the
suspect in this remain costing over time
do externalities exist does a single
intervention meet most needs and are
usually good at predicting what
interventions will work for them
so the structure of this talk is going
to be first time with to introduce to
habit lab behavior change platform then
I wouldn't discuss as a set of three
studies about them two of them
discussing outcomes one of them
discussing the interventions so with
regress had blood Pavlov as our behavior
change platform and we can only have
12,000 online in the wild active users
across the browser and there's also an
Android version the basic mechanism is
that during onboarding you select sites
or in the Android version apps that you
want to reduce time on and we'll be
calling these goals we have a number of
interventions that help you reduce the
time on these goal sites and apps
there's over 30 interventions available
or across the browser platform as well
as the Android version and just giving
examples of what these look like for
Facebook there's an example of Facebook
specific intervention this one when you
visit Facebook it'll just hide the
newsfeed for you there's another example
of a Facebook specific intervention this
one will inject into newsfeed a timer
indicating how long you've been on
Facebook and then there's an example
some of the interventions are actually
general you can use them on any site
there's an example of them and this one
is this will automatically close tab
after 60 seconds and it is an example
for YouTube specific intervention this
one will show a note it prompts before
you start watching the video how long
the video actually is before it starts
playing here examples of some Android
interventions this one
will is a swim is all the Android
interventions are actually site site
general but they can be using so app
general they can be used on any app so
this one will every time you've this
open an app it will show you a prompt
also your notification showing how many
times
visited this app today this one is one
to actually ask you to be sure are you
really sure you want to go open this app
whenever you try to open it so the
design process by which we actually
arrived at these interventions first we
took a look at existing interventions on
chrome store and basically just
reimplemented them in habit lab itself
we had a number of ideas that were
proposed by experts and our users and we
also adapted techniques that we found in
the behavior change literature we have
over 12,000 daily active users that are
from 151 countries of those about 30%
are from the United States 50% of them
prefer to use their browser in English
and most of represented age demographic
is 25 to 34 years of age our users are
also mostly male so in the process of
actually growing habit lab we actually
follow the number of design principles
so one of them is firstly if you have to
design for good user experience because
because your our users are completely
voluntary and if the user experience is
not good they're going to uninstall
right so we had to Impala SH the
products we spent a lot of time removing
bugs and one of the things we made sure
to do is avoid logging on brain surveys
and excessive experience sampling that
would degrade the user experience when
we were unsure what would be the beyond
the optimum to maximize you tension we
actually ran a number of a B test find
good default would maximize retention we
also gave people plenty of can use to
leave feedback so if got the habit lab
extension there these little feedback
forums where you can just send feedback
whenever you find a bug or something
that can be improved what if you
uninstall had the lab will show this on
installation survey where you can ask we
can say why you're uninstalling we got a
number we leave we got a number of
emails from you from users about this is
actually just from this morning actually
and we have a little reddit where people
can just post their ideas about like the
future directions how blab should take
we have a github where people can report
bugs and request features and we also
have a number of opportunities for our
users to contribute for example ideas
for interventions themselves we give
people opportunities to contribute
internationalisation is actually quite
amazed
we actually have parts of a blab it
translated into 13 different languages
just by completely volunteer users on
transifex and we also have opportunities
for users to contribute in terms of code
we actually have a intervention editor
built into habit lab itself to allow
people to write their own interventions
and people actually use this this to
actually write interventions which we
have actually merged into made to have a
lab code base but in terms of what
actually led to big growth it actually
turned out that that is actually a lot
based on like the press so I was like
initially we had like we were like
floating around 80 users like most half
of whom were Arab like my lab mates and
then and then like life acted all of a
sudden like somebody just just found the
accession just thought it was really
cool wrote an article and then like
office uh never be like all the other
mainstream press like New York Times
Wired its and like a number of Chinese
sites just copied its and we have like
huge numbers after night okay
so that's basically a blob how it built
it and how we grew it and so now we're
going to go talk about some of the
studies that we ran on the habit lab
platform the first one is a paper that
we presented at CSC W 2018 titled
rotating online behavior change
interventions increase effectiveness but
also increases attrition
so basically theory has shown a number
of the airglow work has shown that here
we change interventions these suffer
from decline engagement over time and
that their novelty effects that can
provide temporary boost engagement
that's it if we look at existing
behavior change systems they tend to be
used stack interventions and so they're
not really making full use of this
novelty effect so this leads us to a
research question of well can a strategy
of rotating interventions help improve
effectiveness and so the first
hypothesis that we made is that stack
interventions about showing the same
intervention over and over again it's
going to suffer from decreased
effectiveness over time that is the
amount of time that you spend on the
site is once you increase over time
second hypothesis is that rotation is
going to increase the intervention
effectiveness so so we first ran a pair
of studies that are in the investigating
rotating versus intervention stack
interventionist
so the first one was a within subject
experience where we are comparing it's
rotating in tact intervention strategies
in terms of effectiveness of
interventions over time that we measure
in terms of Daly's time that users are
spending on the sites as well as the
attrition rates and we've measured
attrition as the amount of time that the
user keeps thing installed until the
uninstall so this is within subjects
design with 2 inches 17 participants our
conditions were that on some days you
just saw the same intervention which we
call the static condition and others the
interventions change every Road visit
which we call the rotating intervention
shins condition and so we organized the
conditions into blocks of 1 3 5 or 7
days so basically we would we randomized
how long is a block of interventions
you're going to get so it would be
obviously counter balanced in that in
that in that you would have one day of
stack interventions probably one they
have rotation for example or if there's
a there's a block length of 3 then you'd
have three days of rotated rotation
followed by three days of static and for
example here five days of rotation
followed by five days of stack and these
of course can all be these are all
randomized in order so what we want to
figure out was do stack interventions
decline in effectiveness over time and
in order to investigate this we use the
linear mixed model where fixed effects
were the number of days that the
intervention had been seen the random
effects was the user ID and the domain
and the dependent variable was the time
that that was spent on the domain on
that day and we log normalized this or
that way to get normal distributions and
so what we found here is that time that
spent on on the sites increases over
time with stack interventions so what
this means that there's actually
declined and effectiveness over time so
so just we can actually interpret these
these numbers from our linear mixed
model by exponentiating
these predicted log time per on on site
and basically what it tells us that if
our model predicts that on day one the
users going to be spending 116 seconds
per site and on day two and day three
there's going to be recipe increasing so
the second question that we want to
investigate is whether or not rotation
reduces the amount of time that's spent
so this time again our random effects
stars
domain as before and again as dependent
variable we're investigating the time
spent on domain that day but this time
we're considering the condition whether
it's static or rotating interventions as
well as the block length and here we
find that if the rotation if the
condition is is a rotation then the long
time spent per days is going to decrease
that is the daily time on sites it's
actually reduced in the relation
convicted condition that is rotated
rotation is actually making the
interventions more effective so one last
thing that we want to investigate is
whether or not rotation actually
increases attrition so for to do this
what we used was a Cox Hazard regression
and here we were predicting the survival
probability as a function of the
condition within the first block so this
is a visualization of how Cox hazard
works basically we have all the users
during the first day and then and then
on the x-axis we see the days that the
hab lab remains installed and in other y
axis we see the survival probability
that is the probability that they still
have it installed at that time and here
we're looking at the first seven days
that is the first week and as you can
see the stock interventions is actually
higher than then rotating intervention
so start we have 74% remaining after
week but with rotation we only have 52%
remaining after a week so what we found
is that rotating interventions improves
effectiveness but increases attrition in
our first study our second study was
between subjects experiments in which in
which what we sought to see is whether
or not rotating between more
interventions increases the amount of
attrition this time we use the between
subjects design with 409 participants
over the course of five weeks and the
conditions deferred a number of
interventions that were being rotated
between so if the three conditions work
we had one intervention per site so
there's effectively equivalence to the
static condition in a previous study
half of all interventions available so
for example Facebook at the time we had
total of eight interventions in the half
of all interventions condition you get
four of them and there's also the all
interventions available per site's
condition in which for example you get
all eight of the
you'd be rotating between all eight of
the interventions for baseball and again
here we see a hazard progression
and what we find is that rotating
between interventions itself increases
attrition so the top one the one with
the least attrition is if you have just
one intervention that is stack
interventions after 70 days of 47
percent of users are still installed but
in the half condition only 27 percent
are installed and in all condition only
20 percent are installed and there's
only a significant difference between
the one in all condition no difference
between half and all so what this was
suggest is that rotating rotation itself
is what's causing attrition rather than
the number of interventions being
rotated between so to investigate why so
what we want to see next was why this
intervention rotation itself was causing
attrition so you saw some positive
feedback so whenever you used to
uninstall habit lab we get that we show
them still install survey which is of
course perfectly optional but some users
actually tell us why they're why they
are uninstalling and we went to often
analyzed and code these D responses and
one of the key themes that we saw was
that users had incorrect mental models
so this is a quote from user didn't seem
what I expected install to Mexico and
removed it there's also a lot of
dissatisfaction with particular
interventions so it is mostly the bar
covering Facebook message indicators
this is a particular intervention we had
for in have lab so so what we think is
that the causes for why rotini
interventions cause increased attrition
was one we're violating users mental
models and that users perhaps last
lacked a sense of control over their
interventions so so we believe that
rotation violates mental models and so
and so what we wanted to do was we want
to improve users mental models about
rotating intervene interventions and our
third study so we want to see how we can
reduce attrition when intervention
rotation happens to investigate this we
develop two different dialogues that are
shown when intervention is first seen
the first one is is the mental model you
design the second one called the user
control design the mental model design
basically the first time you see a new
intervention it's going to show this
prompt and it'll tell you have a lab
rotates between different nudges each
time you visit sites in this case
Facebook this is the first time you're
seeing in the description of the
intervention and what it does and just
okay so this is just telling people that
intervention rotation is happening and
this is the intervention you're seeing
the user control design is identical to
the previous one except this time we
actually add this little slider where
you can actually up to turn off the
intervention on future visits note that
this is not a new feature in the other
conditions you can also go to the
options setting and turn it off this one
just makes a little more salient that
they actually have this control and they
can turn off the information if they
don't like it so in order to investigate
this we use that between subjects design
with 284 a 282 participants over the
course of ten days and the conditions
were deferring according to which sign
was was shown when intervention was
first seen so where there's none none
condition where no design was shown when
the first when they first saw the
intervention that is equivalent to the
previous studies that we had mentioned
there was the mental model design where
we should the one has that just told
them you're seeing interventions rotate
does the intervention yeah and there's
the rotate the user control design in
which we also in addition to mental
model design given this little option to
turn off that intervention right there
by clicking a button run we found that
the mental model design reduces
attrition by half that is after a as if
you have no in in the baseline condition
without either of the either these
designs only 43% of users are remaining
after seven days but in the mental model
condition 78% of you just remain after
78 days and in the user control control
condition also 78% of users remain after
77 days and there's a significant
difference between the the non end
mental model conditions so we find is
that is that this design of reminding
people that interventions are rotating
to improve their mental models actually
have the amount of attrition that occurs
during the first week okay so this was
the this is a paper that we presented
csw 2018 and the basically the key
findings were that stack interventions
declined effectiveness over time
rotating interventions improved as
effectiveness but at the cost of
increased attrition
attrition can be we believe is due to
incorrect mental models and a lack of
control and we can reduce the attrition
with a simple design that improves users
mental models okay so so that was the
first sort of studies that we ran on to
have a laptop yes yes
so I guess even though there was no
difference between statistically between
the mental model and the control
conditions kind of intuitively like like
it doesn't really a cue pie too much
additional space to like give them that
little option and there were indeed in
their qualitative feedback like a lot of
like like using like things that kind of
indicate that users weren't really aware
that he could turn off interventions
even though it was like who explicitly
made clear during onboarding so so yeah
so what we ultimately did was we just
went forward with the the control
condition the user control condition
right so like every time you see the new
intervention that couldn't have a lab
you're always going to be seeing that
little option to turn it often the
reminder yeah okay okay so this is going
to be this next set of studies the grant
habit lab this is a study of looking at
whether or not externalities exist in
our system and this is a paper called
other pacific highway 19 called
conservation procrastination do prior to
the intervention save time or just
redistributed so we saw this slide
earlier and and as I said they're number
part to the tools that help you just
reduce their amount of time online
including rescue time stay focused and
of course our own habitat and our
question here is is that time that we
that we save actually saved or is just
being redirected to other unproductive
activities so we all often assume that
interventions are isolated so if you are
Facebook and we have an intervention
that's acting on Facebook of resulting
in a decline in time on Facebook we
assume that other sites for example
YouTube the amount of time you spend on
those it's going to be unaffected
likewise we assume that if we have
interventions acting on one device we
assume that the amount of time spent on
other devices is also won't be
unaffected
and we're going to post this question of
well maybe that time is that you're
saving on one side is just being shifted
elsewhere so just to give you some
theoretical intuition as to why this
might be happening we have a limited
supply of fuel power and we needed
breaks in down time so if your
intervention is preventing you from
getting that that that break maybe
you're going to go elsewhere to get that
break so this leads us to this
hypothesis of well maybe they make this
conservation cost nation defect we're
reducing time on one side or app for
example reducing time and Facebook is
actually going to be tune increase in
time on the other apps like YouTube
because well you didn't get your fix on
Facebook so you're going to go to
youtube to get it right
likewise uh likewise reducing time one
device might increase in time on the
others as well so but there's a third
possibility
well maybe interventions might actually
have benefits outside the tops the apps
that they are targeting and the
theoretical justification but this is
that absolute designed to be habit
building and it results in this habit
loop of constantly checking your sites
in oral and and phones so maybe if you
manage to break this habit loop well
you're going to also decrease the repeat
visits and reduce the amount of time
elsewhere so there's breaking a bloop
resultant further decreases in time
spent elsewhere well maybe if the
intervention reducing the time on
Facebook if we break that loop and as a
result time other sites like YouTube is
also going to decrease or likewise if
you reduce your time on your computer
your time on your phone is also going to
decrease it coin this theory so for a
first research question we want to
investigate whether how interventions on
one side your app are influencing time
on other sites and apps and so when
you're just time on one app or site
there's three possibilities we consider
isolation there's no one there's no
change there's the possibility of
increasing at a time on other sites and
apps which we call the redistribution
hypothesis and there's possibility of
decreasing enough time on other sites
and apps which we call the reduction
hypothesis likewise we have another
research question asking the same thing
at the level of devices if you reduce x
on one device P interventions how is the
amount of time spent on other devices in
changed again same isolation
redistribution reduction hypotheses so
so the first thing that we want to do
before we actually start in
investigating this question is we also
confirm just as a sanity check that
interventions actually work and are
actually reducing the amount of time on
the focal core because that was kind of
the purpose it's for there's the pre
requested assumption so in order to
investigate this question what we do is
for each goal we randomly assign it to
one of two conditions each week we have
a frequent condition in which on every
visit to yours on every visit that is
every time you visit the sites on the
browser platform where every time you
open an app on the Android platform
we're going to show an intervention
every single visit and then there's the
infrequent condition in which only 20%
of visits we're going to be showing
intervention this infrequent condition
was actually intended to approximate no
interventions the reason we want for
infrequent as opposed to no intervention
at all is because when users install a
blab they're expecting to get
interventions and so if we if they say
and we're like oh if all of these
interventions and you get no
intervention they're like oh it is
broken until uninstalling give us zero
stars right so this is the closest we
can do so what we do here is we compare
these daily time spent on the days in in
which the users were in the frequent
condition compared to the infrequent
conditions for every one of the goals
and so this was done over the course of
five point eight weeks with 1034 users
on the browser and 876 teachers on the
balcony on the mobile version so the
first finding we found was that
interventions are effective on both
platforms
there's 7.3 percent reduction in the
daily time spent on the browser version
this this is really significant and
there's 37 percent reduction in the time
spent on the Android version on the
frequent weeks compared to the
infrequent weeks also statistically
significant so so the so in our first
study we found that indeed our effects
our interventions are actually effective
at reducing time on the focal Gloor so
next we're going to actually study the
the the research questions that we posed
in in the beginning firstly how is the
time we distribute to other sites on the
same platform yeah
okay if I install it am I asking to
opting ending his experiments are you
separating yeah so for each of these
experiments we basically start them and
we always use fresh users yeah like so
so each of these like all the 5,000
users that we've mentioned here with
those are only users who are starting to
install after we launched this thing in
terms of do we recruit a separate pool
when you install the thing the first
page that you get is this little IRB
notification which is like by installing
happy lab we often - all the experiments
and we collect all your data and so yeah
we don't collect separately yeah I guess
it depends on the the rate at which the
people are coming in I think like at the
time I was running this particular
experience I think I had around like 50
to 50 installs per day or something like
that so yeah the it takes a few months
to collect these yeah all right so okay
so to investigate whether or not time is
redistributed within the pot within at
the same platform what we did was we
developed this metric of how intense
interventions are this date which we'll
call intensity and we defined intensity
as the percentage of sessions on a goal
that triggered intervention so for
example if you visit 10 times nice
austere interventions then the value of
the entities might be zero if you visit
Facebook ten times and you saw three
interventions then ian has to go and pee
0.3 and we verified that days when the
interest is higher then the overall time
the goal is going to be significantly
lower on both the platforms so so in
order to the manipulation we did was
that we randomly assigned each goal to
have either a frequent or infrequent
interventions each week and because you
just have a number of different in goals
that they are being randomized across
this actually resulted in continuous
intensity value value that's from zero
to one so the first study we want to do
is is see whether when days on days one
of the interview
density is higher what is the effect on
the time spent on the non ghoul absent
sites and we did here was again a linear
mixed model where the fixed effect was
the intensity the random fact was the
user and we want to see what the total
effect on non well sites that is by
reducing like when the audacity is
higher on on the focal goals what is the
effect on the other non non goal sites
and we find is that is that if the
intensity is higher which is resulting
in lower time on on the focal sites
there's actually a reduction in the time
spent on the other sites when the
intensity is higher there's 15%
reduction of time estimated when the in
has to increase from zero to one
sniffing the current shape are element
on mobile we find no significant effect
of time on of one app on the other apps
so returning to our first research
question when we reduce time on one site
via via our intervention what is the
effect on the other ones we find that in
the case of the browser its reduction
time on the other apps actually
decreases but in the case of mobile is
actually isolation there's no effect as
to why this occurs respect that because
there's number of aggregator sites
search Facebook that often linked to
other domains so by reducing the amount
of time on our Facebook we reduced time
other domains because you're not going
to be going to Facebook following these
links and then going off to these other
sites as well on mobile with the reason
we suspect there is no effect is that
mobile apps are mostly messaging
oriented rather than aggregators and
sessions are short and often followed by
turning off the screen so unlike the
browser case where you're going to be
where the where Facebook goes often like
drives you to two other sites in this
case you because a facebook will respond
to your short message or whatever and
just turn off the screen we do actually
have the particular site or application
being intervened on in this in the
analysis so yeah
so this does account for that we also
looked at at the let's see LT like what
was most commonly selected I also did
like this I also did this is announced
individually on particular apps I did
find that like for example for like
Facebook for Facebook and reddit I think
the the browser in fact did hold it was
like a number of other non I rated sites
on which we didn't observe that effect
so um so yeah I do believe that it was
read and read in the platform however if
you look at the site types of apps that
people are choosing what we found is
that the most common like ten ones that
like that people are saying they want to
reduce time on on mobile they're like
most TVs messaging oriented absent very
few aggregator type apps and on the
browser they were like the book worth I
create a type apps yeah yeah also
another thing is that many mobile apps
like Facebook the embed embed browser so
visiting external links will will remain
within the same app ok so so returning
to our first research question we want
to see whether reducing time on one site
is going to reduce time elsewhere and we
find is that on the browser we observed
this reduction effect but on mobile
where it's isolation finally we want to
observe whether or not time this
redistributed across devices so here we
want to see you as one times higher
methodology we used especially the same
as in the cross within the platform case
except this times width between devices
so when intensity is higher on one
device what is the total effect of time
spent on Google Sites on the other
device we we had a smaller size because
we need to have participants we're using
a blob on both the mobile and the the
the chrome platforms at the same time we
managed to figure out who was who just
by having them allowing them to log in
in this case we can use the linear mixed
model the same structure accepts at this
time where we're looking at intensity on
this device as opposed to on on a
targeted app or site we find that
there's no significant effect on either
in either direction of browser intensity
of interventions of browser
interventions on
by all time or mobile intensity on
browser
okay so just returning to our second
research question in this case its
isolation in both directions as to why
there we didn't observe any class device
it affects firstly laptops and phones
are used in different contexts so so
perhaps like we wouldn't expect any kind
of interaction there and also another
thing is that unlike browsers in which
like for example in Facebook there's
actually like these links which you
click on that bringing to other sites
there's no such thing as a cost device
link there's relatively few apps or
sites that start prominent prompting you
to use the other device with your
subtype for example two-factor
authentication so so basically we found
that time is not redistribute
across devices for answer to our
question of whether time is redistribute
across devices so to a discussion of
this study is that we didn't observe
negative secondary effects of the
productivity interventions on either
other sites product apps or devices
which is actually a really good thing
because we because we started with this
little horror story of oh the part to be
introduced aren't actually doing
anything is just shifting time around
and it turns out that that's actually
not the case and in fact on browsers we
actually have this beneficial effect in
that reducing time when one site is
actually go introduced time or others we
should believe to be mostly Jews data
greater sites so in terms of the
implications of this when we're
designing your interventions we should
consider effects on not just the tired
behavior but on the workflow as a whole
and of course there's a number of
limitations to this work firstly we're
only monitoring time on the phones and
the browsers so for example if the time
is being redistribute to non digital
activity so for example you're reducing
the time on the browser on Facebook or
whatever but the result is you're
watching TV we can't observe that right
because because we can't monitor that we
also only Ceyda positively domain so so
we should be very careful about about
generalizing this result of there's no
negative secondary effects to other
behavior change domains I don't make
that claim so just so just to summarize
we looked at whether or not reducing
time via introduced reduce time spent
elsewhere within
device we found out there's a reduction
effect on the browser but non mobile
cost device we didn't observe
we believe the reduction effect on the
browser was due to a greater size
driving traffic to other sites and on
the cross device cases because users we
didn't observed any effects because
devices are used in different contexts
okay so so this was a paper we presented
had twenty twenty nineteen okay
so for a final four final study we're
now investing about how users in
preferences change over time so just
remind you whenever users uninstall we
have this little prompt that that we
asked why are they install and one of
the interesting things we found was that
use actually have very different
expectations for what they want
productivity tools to do so
we had many users who say that
interventions are too hard but a lot of
users were like the impressions are too
easy so this of course leads us to a
rather tricky situation in that we can't
satisfy both of the users without
personalized personalization
so we default was well our first initial
thought was well we can just classified
the intervention difficulties and then
just ask the users during onboarding
what difficulty you'd like to prefer and
just show them that so that isn't in
fact what we did and so here this is a
screen that we show during onboarding in
which we ask them how aggressive do you
want have a lot to be in helping you
reduce your time alone we gave them four
options first firstly there's the don't
do anything there's no interventions
ease light-touch would just easy
interventions medium interventions were
hard interventions and this is how it
the distribution of how users choose
them is across 5,000 users and and
basically the ranking is from it's easy
medium hard and nothing is though is the
order in which they choose them and
these are all statistically significant
pairs according to a chi-square test and
one thing that you might want to note is
that only eight point eight percent of
the users that's the fewest is a are
saying that they want no intervention at
all as well observe is actually going to
change so so firstly users are really
optimistic initially about how difficult
they want their interventions with no
intervention being the least frequently
chosen category during onboarding
so this leads us to question well okay
so you just said that is the during on
boring that these they're the difficulty
in furnace that they think is going to
work well for them well do their
preferences change over time are these
predictions during our boring actually
accurate and to investigate this what we
did was we gave this little experience
sampling option in which every time you
visit the site we're going to ask the
users about the intervention difficulty
preference that they have for this
particular visit so basically every time
you visit the site you can say I want
for this visit no intervention or an
easy intervention or a medium
intervention or hard intervention and
here we do is we plot for users over
time the the choices that they make in
this experience sampling prompt and so
we have this here we have 223 users who
who answered this question at least 200
times and and basically the the colors
they can decode what interventions they
chose during this experience sampling
prompt so the start blue is the new
intervention and and easy medium hard as
you get closer and closer to yellow and
one of the interesting things we
observed is that at the start there's
actually a lot of color changes that
we're just representing a lot of initial
exploration between the different
different intervention difficulties but
over time I've got about 100 you
actually looked at the intervention
preferences are actually mostly stable
with the users responding fairly
consistently with their preferred
intervention difficulty do I see the
white it's actually on so it's every
time you visit so basically this is
going to be multiple times per day yeah
yeah and so and so initially what we see
is that there are some relatively few
Jews who say no intervention with only
29 of them fairly consistently choosing
from the start I want no intervention
but by the end about 119 out of 223
users that is the majority are
consistently choosing top no
intervention so we see is that is that
even though
at the start no intervention is the
least frequently chosing option after
after different using the system for a
while eventually half of the users are
eventually choosing no intervention
almost all time and this is just a
question of like can we determine
whether than when this intervention
difficulty preference is changing that
is how frequently do we need to ask ask
them to get these accurate results and
what are the costs of asking so in terms
of the amount of time that that costs
users to actually choose this difficulty
pump so that we showed this little
experience sampling metric and then the
amount of time that from when it's shown
to the actually click the button we
actually look at this is actually 1.2
seconds so the time cost of the
experience sampling is actually quite
low that said if less than they as
passed since their last asked if the
user are less likely to answer it so the
logistics ignore the prompt entirely so
just want this is the one day point if
it's less than that if you're asking me
more if it's been less than a day since
they last saw that that prompt there's
lower response rates it's been more than
day it actually looks fairly level
around a bit more than one that's your
point five percent response based a 50
percent response rate per visit and one
of the other things we find is that if
we vary the frequency at which we we
showed this experience sampling so
between zero point between zero percent
probability of getting the thing 25% 50%
or 100% we find that that when we have
it more frequent this increases
attrition so in terms of how frequently
need to ask to get accurate results it's
actually we find that prediction I
previously declines as sampling
frequency decreases and that if you're
sampling once a day you actually get
fairly accurate results at about eighty
percent so so so daily still gets fairly
reasonably high accuracy so we find that
the desired difficulty can be predicted
quite well with periodic experience
sampling so
summarize what this projects been
finding so far we find that the users
preferences are changing over times and
maybe once a day should be getting good
balance between accuracy and camping
costs but of course what do you use
actually prefer in terms of how
frequently we'd be asking them so in
order to figure out when it was the
users preference here we changed this
experience sampling things so that
instead of just asking dead for
difficulty for this time we also ask
them about when she asked you next about
difficulty and we give them options of
ask again next visit one hour later from
one day later one week later and we find
that here there's actually have two
things that emerge firstly some users
they actually want to be asked every
single time
oh and also there's not apps walk outs
this is how many users will choose most
frequently this option but the number of
other users they choose the week once a
week next week option so which is the
least frequent option and if we look at
the combination the intersection of of
which which which options we were
choosing we find that the most common
intersection is I want to have no
intervention but ask me again next visit
so so user actually like very optimistic
and hopeful Weber they're basically
saying I don't want an intervention this
visit but ask me again next time maybe
I'll maybe I'll change my mind and one
thing that you may want to to note with
that is that these users are all people
who kept this installed so so they're
not just saying like I haven't tired of
intervention um what uninstall they are
actually keeping the thing installed and
yet still continually choosing I want no
intervention but maybe I'll change my
mind okay so so one of the interesting
things we found was that well it looks
like if we give people choices many of
them we're eventually going to start
gravitating towards the easy path and it
looks like somebody is actually somewhat
aware of this this is a this is a common
tendon or song on reddit like right
around when I started this this
experiment I find myself mindlessly
clicking don't do anything would prefer
to have nudges on by default without an
option to determine the same abstract
before each Facebook business so this
you just busily acknowledging well these
choices he doesn't really have the like
the good level of control to to control
himself and like say like I don't want
any nudges so he'd rather you don't even
have the choice so we went ahead and
investigate this what happens when we
removed the choices so if we ask the
users for the initial preferences during
onboarding well you know what those
preferences and just randomly assign
them to various different in different
intervention level it's goatee levels
and then what we did was the wish find
interestingly attrition rates actually
there's no effect of this this was
significant effect on the attrition
levels this is shown with the Cox
regression so no significant differences
in attrition rates between if you're
assigning them to no intervention easy
medium hard and actually randomly
assigning these intervention levels
improves do you have efficacy of
interventions so we showed here is the
more total time spent daily on sites in
each of the conditions based on what you
randomly assigned to and and there's
less time spent with the Hart
interventions in samples t-tests shows
this is necessarily significant so what
we find is that assigning users harder
interventions worst help combat these
issues so this leads to an interesting
discussion where we start this project
with the intention of well we're going
to be more personalized and help respect
these user preferences but we find that
actually randomly assigning an employer
interaction seems to actually perform
better than giving them a choice that's
a record like to be able to preferred to
respect these user preferences and so
perhaps one potential solution we can
investigate is maybe we can solve this
by changing set the set of choices so
for instance in a healthy eating domain
maybe instead of giving there's the
choice between the fries or the salad
made the choice between broccoli or the
spinach Andy there's a number of studies
that that show that the choice that the
user makes
depends on the set of options that you
give them likewise when maybe instead of
giving users Detroit actually the choice
I don't want to see an intervention
maybe make the choice between the
intervention a and B where they're both
pretty hard or like effective
interventions and this is of course that
that last bit is future work so to
summarize this project we found is that
use different the preferences for the
intervention difficulty there they
overestimate your motivation if over
time they eventually gravitate toward
having no interventions at all and that
we give them harder intervention without
asking that improves the outcomes so
this leads us to a conclusion so what we
did was so so we investigated behavior
change systems effects on on users and
we find that the change that these
effects change constantly that as users
preferences during onboarding may not
still be true a week later and initial
observation effectiveness are subject to
novel novelty effects
additionally there are secondary effects
in addition to the tired outcomes so by
reducing the time on our ater sites time
elsewhere it is also reduced all those
one this was what one of our stays found
and therefore the recommendations that
we make is that we should perhaps
periodically be doing some experience
sampling and change and change to adapt
to the users as possible we should not
assume that everything during onboarding
is going to be true forever likewise
when we do our measurements taking the
account that their secondary effects we
should be measuring outcomes
holistically ok in terms of future work
they're there of course behavior change
technologies that organizing theories
for how behavior change interventions
can work so if we want to investigate
how these in theories actually work how
much was due the fears actually matter
and so what we're doing currently is
implementing interventions that cover a
behavior change taxonomy and measuring
depression affecting this nutritional
aids for each of them in terms of more
distant future work um what we focus so
far here is online behavior change but
with the increasing ubiquity of sensors
and wearables could we build crops in
the wild behavior change platform in the
physical world so this leads to a
statement of in the world wild
experimentation is a powerful tool to
gain insights about behavior change
systems are at scale specifically allows
to conduct a wide wide variety of
studies about in interventions and their
outcomes in terms of acknowledgments
this course Michael Bernstein are my
advisor I had a number of wonderful
undergraduates and master students who
contribute to this work and of course
I'd wonderful lab mates in the HCA group
that made this possible so that
concludes my talk just to summarize we
we built the system habit lab and we can
do three different studies the first one
we found that in terms of effectiveness
remaining constant as time passes we
find that the effectiveness of stacking
dimensions falls over time and row
helps in terms of externalities we've
found that on browsers reduced in time
one site released reductions elsewhere
but we didn't find other externalities
and we found that in terms of changes in
user preferences over time we find that
you just initially choose harder
interventions and the choice of
difficulty falls over time
[Applause]